ก็
[เพลง]
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักดีเฮียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนคุณดูเหมือนอ่ะมีอะไร
เยอะแยะที่ต้องทำค่ะไฟฟ้ากันถ้าเป็นคน
เยอะค่ะเข้าใจค่ะผู้ฟ้าถ.
วันอะไร
วันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายน
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  020  225 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 1
เดือนเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตตปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศ
phaw
2022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 3 เดือนเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตตปีพต 2  565
ถ้าไม่ตรงนะคะปีคศปีข้อหรอ 2  02
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา
8:00 นเรามากกีนาที
08:15 น
8 โมง 15 นาทีนะคะเป็นตอนกลางวันนอนแล้ว
ก็เป็นตอนเช้า
ฉาบหนาวเอาแบบชาวมากใช่ชายนักเรียนมีอีก
อะไรคะผู้หญิงก็อยู่ที่บ้านใช่ไหมคะ
ผู้หญิงยู
คิดค่ะครูหญิงไม่ได้อยู่ที่บ้านค่ะครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้อยู่ที่บ้านแล้วผู้หญิงจะ
อยู่ที่ไหนโกหกเก่งอยู่คอนโดค่ะ
The
Condominium
คอนโดมิเนียมหรือว่าว่าคนไทยก็พูดว่าบ้าน
เอาไปถามโทรฟ้าทำไมถามว่าครูหญิงผู้หญิง
อยู่ที่บ้านไหม
เพราะว่ากูป๋าน่ะมีเกมมาให้กูหญิงเล่น
กูมาโลน
vk มาให้คุณหญิงเล่น
นักเรียนบอกว่านักเรียนเนี่ยดูวีดีโอครู
หญิงกับครูฟ้ามันนานๆแต่กรูฟ้าเล่นเกมวัน
นี้ครูหญิงเล่นเกมเย้
ๆอ้าว
มีเกมอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เกมให้ครูหญิงเนี่ยคิดหักผู้หญิงต้องคิด
นะคะโอ๋โอ๋อันนี้กูหญิงใช่ไหมคะมีผู้หญิง
เนี่ยตาโต
จมูกโด่ง
ปากเล็กๆและครูหญิง
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยต้องคิดหรอ
คิดค่ะครูหญิงหญิงต้องคิดเพราะครูฟ้า
เนี่ยจะมี
มีอะไรคะใหญ่ไปมั้ยเนี่ย
มีสี่เสียงให้ครูหญิงฟัง
ผู้หญิงต้องใช้หูใหญ่เนี่ยฟังเสียงฟัน
เสร็จใหญ่แล้วก็คิดหรอคะว่าเสียงอะไร
ใช่ผู้หญิงต้องฟังฟังฟังฟังฟังๆคนแล้วค่ะ
แล้ว
ผู้หญิงก็คิดครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ให้คุณผู้หญิงฟังเสียงอะไรโด๋
[เพลง]
นี้เลยค่ะครูฟ้า
นักเรียนก็ฟังด้วยนะคะแล้วนักเรียนก็คิด
ว่าเสียงอะไรเหมือน
ได้เลี้ยงแรก
กูเพราะว่าเอาง่ายๆก่อนละกันเปลี่ยนที่ 1
อะไรเนี่ยที่ 1 สิ่งที่ 1 แป๊บนึงนะคุย
ต้องเงียบก่อนวิ่งก็เงียบๆนะคะผู้หญิงไป
เงียบหรือยังคะผู้หญิงเงียบไปยังวิ่ง
เงียบๆนะคะ
ผู้หญิงแล้วครูฟ้าสัตว์
ปิดปากได้ไหม
เสียงที่หนึ่ง
ฉันจะ
ฟ้าทองเสียงแล้วหรอคะกูยังไม่ได้ยินเสียง
อะไรเลยยังไม่ได้ทำไงอันนั้นเองอ่ะ
เอ่อเออ
เห็น
ไม่เห็นหรอ
กูสวยยกขึ้นมาอ่ะผู้หญิงฟังแล้วกูหญิงคิด
ว่าคุณฟ้านะพี่แก้ว
her หมูป่าก็มีครัว
ต.ยขวดเนี่ยมีน้ำแล้วครู Fast เนี่ย
ก็เอา
อ่ะแบบผู้หญิงอ่ะพี่ช่วยลากลงมาหน่อยได้
ไหมคะนักเรียนมองไม่เห็นนะคะครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าเป็นเสียงเทน้ำค่ะ
เทน้ำไปไหนอ้าวทรูค่ะ
ลองโทร
กูรักเนี่ยอาชุบฟ้ามีขวดน้ำเห็นไหม
ขวดน้ำก็หาแล้วก็แก้วน้ำ
แล้วผู้หญิงก็เทน้ำนะคะคุณน้าคุณฟ้าก็เท
น้ำ
เห็นไหมผู้หญิงถูกต้องเย้
แล้วครูฟ้าก็ดื่มน้ำไม่ใช่ถ้าไม่ดื่มข้อ
ที่ 2 ค่ะ
ข้อที่ 2 ฝั่งนะฟัง
ไม่ได้ยินเลย
ไม่ได้ยิน
ไม่ค่อยได้ยินเลยค่ะ
เอาใหม่นะจะเอาใหม่เอาใหม่
ไม่มีเสียงเลยภูฟ้า
ซุ้มโอเค
ไม่ได้ยินแป๊บนึงนะกูฟ้าขอ
อันนี้หาเขาต้องเป็นอันนี้แน่นอน
สู้มันตัดเสียงใช่ไหมคะอ่ะ
จะอยู่หน้าได้ยินมั้ยได้ยินได้ยินพอพ.ศ.
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีมี่ถุง
นะคะน่าจะเป็นถุงขนมถุงเลย์เป็นถุง
พลาสติกแล้วครูฟ้าก็เอามือ
และบีบบีชทัวร์แล้วแหละบีบถุงคลาสสิกไม่
ใช่ไหมเป็นลูกแก้วชีสถุงพลาสติกใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิง
[ปรบมือ]
เตด้วยถูกต้องนะคะเพราะมิลเลนักเรียนเลว
เป็นขนมค่ะแล้วก็พาก็
ไง
คลาสสิกผู้หญิงเก่งมากเก่งมากค่ะคุณอ่ะ
3 เขาต้องลองซิ
ฟังดีๆนะคะผู้หญิงฟังดีๆอ่ะ
พี่ปุ้ย
นี้กูมาทำเหรอเปล่าบ้านอย่างว่าแล้วเชียว
ผู้หญิงคิดว่า
ว่า
น่าจะเหมือนแบบมีต้นไม้แล้วกันเอาต้นไม้
ไม่ใช่แล้วอ่ะ
ถ้า
ผู้หญิงคิดใหม่สิ่งคิดว่าเป็นเสียงพอได้
[เพลง]
เปิดคิดไหวเรื่อยๆคุณฟ้าผู้หญิงคิดว่า
เสียง
รองเท้าอา
รองเท้าใช่มั้ยรองเท้าส้นสูงแล้วก็มีพื้น
เนี่ยพื้นเนี่ยเป็นพื้นไม้ใช้เป็นต้นไม้
แล้วก็คนเนี้ยเดินเสียงเดินใส่รองเท้าส้น
สูงเดินใช่ไหมคะ
[เพลง]
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิง
จริงมาก
ถ้าคู่ฟ้าไม่เปิดครั้งที่ 2 ผู้หญิงคิด
ว่าเสียงกับต้นไม้
ไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงมันเป็นเสียงอ่าเสียมีของ
ใครว่าคนใส่รองเท้าส้นสูงแล้วก็เดินเดิน
เกิน
เพลงเพ
ราะที่ 4 ค่ะข้อที่ 4 ฟังนะคะฟัง
[เพลง]
คิดว่าคิดว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยมี
กระดาษ
อ่าแล้วก็ครูฟ้าเนี่ยอุ้ย
กูฟ้าเนี่ย 4
สี่กระดาษกริดคิอต่างๆเนี่ยรู้ฟ้ามี
กระดาษแล้วก็เสียงฉี่กระดาษใช่ไหมคะใช่
ไม่น่าใช่นึกว่าอ่าวให้หรือเปล่า
นักเรียนคิดว่าค่ะ
ไม่เจ็บ
เพลงนี่ไงแล้วเรียนกระดาษใช่ไหมกระดาษนะ
คะโหครู Fast ฉีกไปกี่ครั้งท่านอ่ะ
หมายครั้งน่ะ
ได้ยินได้ยินดังมากชัดมากเลยค่ะครูป่าเย้
เย้
หนูชมตัวเองก็ได้เอ้าออที่ 5 ค่ะครูฟ้า
พร้อมแล้วพร้อม
โอเค
ข้อที่ห้านะคะคุณ
ฟังนะ
แต่
จะ
คิดนะไม่รู้เหมือนกันคือเหมือนเสียง Ping
ไม่รู้ว่ากูไปทำอะไรนะคะแต่ว่า
เหมือนมือใช่มั้ยมือเนี่ย
แล้วเราก็มีเล็บนะเล็บเล็บเล็บเล็บๆ
เหมือนครูฟ้าเอาเล็บอ่ะ
ขูดอะไรสักอย่างเลยอ่ะเหมือนเสียงเล็บ
แล้วก็ขูดเพื่อขูดหรือควร
ขูดขูดไหมหรือขุ่นแม่มันครูฟ้ามีสมุดใช่
ไหมผู้หญิงไม่รู้ว่าอันนี้คืออะไรแต่เล็บ
คุณนะเนี่ยส่วนพูดๆเสียงเล็บขูดและกัน
มันก็ถูกไหมอ่ะอ้าว
ใช่ไหมล่ะถ้าไม่ใช่และก็ผิด
เพราะว่าก็ถูก 50% นะคะผู้หญิงอ้าวถูก
ถูกๆ 50% คืออะไรถูก
ถูกก็ได้กูว่ามันก็ใช่แหละใช่นะผู้หญิงคน
คิดว่ามันใช่อ่ะมันใช่
กูพาทำเสียงอะไรคะเพราะที่ 5 กูฟ้าทำ
เสียงเก่า
คนผิด
ใช่แต่มันเป็นเล็บขูดไงกูป๋าเล็บขูดคูณ
เมืองเก่าก็เก่าไงไปเที่ยวหาผิดผิดทาคู่
หญิง
เืสื้ออย่าร้องอย่าร้อง
โอเคโอเคถ้าต่อไปค่ะมุกอ่อนไปข้อที่ครบ
ข้อต่อไป
ม.ค
ถ้า
พี่ไม่แน่ใจอ่ะอันนี้แล้วกันคุยกับว่ามี
แก้วนะคาเป็นแก้วน้ำเหมือนที่ครูฟ้ามี
แล้วก็อาจจะมีซ่อม
ซ่อม
แล้วก็เอาส้อม
เอาส้อมเนี่ยตีแก้วเสียงส้อมตีแก้วแล้ว
กันของแก้วเพราะก๊อกๆๆแก้ว
ใช่ไหมคะ
ใกล้เคียงทวีสิงห์ใกล้นะไล่แต่ไม่ใช่ซ่อม
มีอะไร
[เพลง]
อะไรคะเสียงอะไรอ่ะ
หัว
ร้อนเหรอ
ไม่ใช่ช้อน
มันมีเสียงน้ำได้ยินไหมได้ยินเสียงน้ำ
หรือว่ามีเสียงมีลูกแก้วลูกแก้วลูกแก้ว
มันคือเสียงเสียงอะไรรู้ฟ้าน้ำแข็งอ่ะ
แต่มันตั้งแต่ก็เพราะแบบมันมีเสียงเหมือน
อะไรเคาะนะคะน้ำแข็งไงน้ำแข็งเอาเวียนนา
เสียงน้ำแข็งนักคือแทง
ผิดอีกแล้วผู้หญิงอย่าร้องมีอีกไม่ย้อน
คุณเว้ามีค่ะข้อที่ 7 ค่ะเสียงอะไรอ่ะ
ขอ
เสียงฝนตกหรอ
ใช่ไหมหน้าไม่รู้ว่ากินว่าเสียงฝนตกอ่ะ
กินไม่ออกแล้วอ่ะ
ใช่ค่ะคุณหญิงเสียงฝนตกค่ะเย้
get เสียงฝนตกหรือว่าเสียงสตาร์ทรถฝนตก
เก่งนะเราจะต้องศาลรถนะคะเสียงฝนตก
หัว
ข้อที่ 8 ค่ะครูฟ้า
ข้อที่ 8 เสียงอะไร
แป๊บนึงนะข้อที่ 8
[เพลง]
ได้ยินชัดมากกว่ากูฝากยิงคิดว่า
เสียงพิมพ์คีย์บอร์ด
เวลาที่แบบคอมพิวเตอร์ใช่ไหมมันก็จะมี
คีย์บอร์ดเนาะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นเฟซใช่ไหมนี่
ก็ Enter เอออันนี้ก็มีปุ่มปุ่มปุ่ม
ปุ่มแล้วก็เป็นสายแล้วก็พิมพ์เสียงพิมพ์
คีย์บอร์ดคิดว่า
ที่
ถูกต้องค่ะผู้หญิง
เก่งคนทีมเหรอลูกสาวพิมพ์พิมพ์พิมพ์พิมพ์
คีย์บอร์ดอีก on รู้ได้ยังไงยี่ห้อนึงได้
มั้ยได้ค่ะมีเวลา
เพราะที่ 9
เสียงอะไร
โห
เดี๋ยวทำกันจะว่ายังไงเนี่ยอันนี้คุณเอา
นี้เหรอไม่เอานั้นหรอว่ามันมันคือมันคือ
คำตอบเดียวกันน่ะแต่ว่าอันนี้ชัดขึ้น
15 นะไม่รู้สึกหรือเปล่าเสียงเขากระดาษ
หรือเปล่ามีกระดาษแล้วก็มีแบบมีไฟแช็ค
แล้วก็จุดไฟเผากระดาษ
มันใกล้ละหรอ
หรือว่าเสียงดับเพลิง
มีรถใช่ไหมพี่โบวล์มาแล้วก็ฉีดน้ำ
ดับไฟอา
แต่มันคือเสียงหญิงอะไรกองไฟเราหญิงก็ถูก
แล้วอะเออแล้วหาผู้หญิงอีกแล้วไม่เสียง
ดับเพลิงมี 5 อย่างนี้อ่ะสีอะไรนะเราไม่
ใช่เสียงเขากระดาษสมัยผู้หญิงอะไรกระดาษ
เนี่ยไม่ใช่แต่เสียงกลองไฟก็ไม่เสียงไฟไป
ไฟใช่วิ่งดอกเสียงไฟถูกต้องมาถูกต้อง
ผู้หญิงเก่งมาก
หญิงหูที่นักเรียนล่ะนักเรียนฟังเสียง
แล้วที่ภูฟ้าเอามาเล่นรู้ไหมว่าเสียงอะไร
นะคะนักเรียนครูกี่ข้อน้องก็คอมเม้นท์บอก
เราได้นะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้ว
เดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ